oh yeah christmas comes a little early
this year a telltale games The Walking
Dead Season 2 episode 1 long title but
that is what it is this is season 2 of
the telltale games Walking Dead series
one of my favorite games of last year
and if you haven't played it you should
play it especially before watching this
video I'm saying you should play it like
I say you should get your driver's
license in life it would just give you a
new perspective on the world at least
the world of games anyway and I'm really
diggin how season 2 is starting out
season 2 you actually play as Clementine
Dan season 1 you played this Li and you
were protective of Clementine you're
like I can't murder people in front of
her but now Lee is gone respect so now
this is about Clementine becoming her
own person coming into her own losing
her innocence which is a sad fact of
life in the zombie apocalypse but it is
the zombie apocalypse she can't be a
little naive Clementine forever as I
make Clementine say in this chapter you
gotta grow up sometime which is really
cool one of the things you notice about
this game is that Clementine has it's
not really like Paragon renegade
dialogue when people are talking with
her you can respond with nice responses
or you can respond with Stern responses
something you're not used to Clementine
doing but it is a really cool character
development for her and I noticed this
at the beginning of the game when
someone's trying to rob me and she looks
at Clementine she's like give me your
hat your Clementine you're like oh [ __ ]
you can have the backpack no one gets
the Hat no human being playing this game
looks like oh yes ma'am no one maybe if
they did that they didn't play season 1
and of course in season 2 you run across
a whole group of people some like
Clementine some don't like Clementine
you know how it is a whole plethora of
personalities and so you interact with
them differently in a way that shows how
Clementine is growing as a person among
the zombie apocalypse which isn't always
nice well you understand it's not like
she's bad no he's an [ __ ] she's not
shooting people in the face or anything
this game plays up the fact that
Clementine is a kid so how does the kids
survive in a world like this that's
everyone's debating about Clementine is
I targeted this one guy and I just gave
him the option was sad eyes I gave him
sad eyes because that's what a little
girl in the zombie apocalypse should do
to survive it's just like it's fine but
just kind of pathetic but hey I'm a
survivor
I stole a watch I don't know if I should
have but I did it I'm just saying I felt
like I should need it for trading fodder
later on which means someone's gonna
hate me for it but you know what
whatever I just won lady in this chapter
she's pregnant she's [ __ ] probably cuz
hormones but she doesn't really like
Clementine and so for some odd reason
when I was interacting with her I was
like no and I just kind of shot a snarky
remark her way and I'm paraphrasing she
was like oh you little [ __ ] don't you
talk to me like that and as Clementine I
responded don't talk to me like that
which is unlike the Clementine we knew
in season one to say something like that
but again this is about her growing and
this is why having the player play as
Clementine in this chapter is so genius
because if you play through season one
you're protective of Clementine innately
you still want to shelter her so when
people start coming at Clementine
verbally you want to tell them hey back
off [ __ ] and so you as the player
make clementines say something like that
so that person knows to back off so your
protective nature as a gamer is
ultimately contributing to Clementine
becoming her own person a confident
person a person who will survive the
zombie apocalypse because Lee isn't
around anymore which is kind of a sad
concept because you like innocent
Clementine but it's really realistic and
you're glad to see her grow my
Clementine shot Lee in the face so she's
already been making hard decisions I
really dug this chapter I'm not gonna
lie apparently the plan is you're gonna
get Walking Dead Season 2 chapters and
then the wolf among us they're gonna
alternate every other month which is
just every month is going to be awesome
that's what I heard if you've played the
telltale games Walking Dead game if you
play the wolf among us and you like the
format which is pretty much everything
awesome about point and click games you
remember from the 90s mixed with
everything cool but the dialogue wheel
and Bioware games you're gonna dig this
game and if you played season 1 of The
Walking Dead I don't know how you
haven't played this yet and if you
didn't know it was out it is out it is
great playing as Clementine is genius
being a part of her world is you
interact and make choices that make her
grow as a character and lose her
innocence and have to make the tough
decisions in the zombie apocalypse I
can't wait to see where this goes but so
far chapter one is awesome it has
intense moments cunning moments it has
really good dialogue and you're
interested to see where these characters
will go over the course of months of
your life as you play this game I'm not
gonna give season two a rating until
it's completely done but so far this is
the best way to start it out Cesar
Millan would be so disappointing to me
though you got to establish yourself as
the pack leader before you feed the dog
the beans don't live and learn among the
zombie apocalypse
so with telltale games Walking Dead
Season 2 episode 1 how do you play what
do you think about it whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]